la historia de TX es corta pero muy
sustanciosa comienza en 2019 cuando fue
fundada por Sam bankman free un joven
que hoy tiene 30 años y que veían en
Wall Street como un niño prodigio de las
monedas digitales en poco tiempo se
convertiría en la segunda plataforma de
intercambio de criptomonedas más grande
del mundo el punto de quiebre vino
cuando hace un par de meses ocurrió una
corrida bancaria que es cuando los
usuarios se retiran los depósitos en
masa de una empresa que comienza a dar
señales de problemas de liquidez si todo
salen al tiempo la llevan a la quiebra
ftx Se declaró efectivamente en
bancarrota el 11 de noviembre y dejó
aproximadamente un millón de clientes
enfrentando pérdidas de miles de
millones de dólares en palabras del
nuevo de la empresa John Ray se trató
simplemente de una malversación de más
de ocho mil millones de dólares a la
antigua o sea tomar dinero de otros y
usarlo para fines propios Como por
ejemplo la compra de lujosas propiedades
en Bahamas también para apuntalar a otra
de sus firmas llamada comida algunos lo
comparan con un esquema ponzi o
piramidal o sea captar dinero del
público y usarlo indebidamente incluso
hay quienes lo llaman minimator haciendo
referencia a Bernard quien es uno de los
grandes estafadores de la historia de
Wall Street al final lo que más les
interesa a los inversionistas es si van
a recuperar su dinero la cruda respuesta
la tuvo el nuevo ceo de TX Este martes
en el congreso nunca recuperaremos todos
esos activos fue lo que dijo este martes